on a ce qui est en train de se jouer sur
le front diplomatique les discussions
avec la russie se poursuivre échange
qualifié tout à l'heure de long et
difficile par singaye lavrov chef de la
diplomatie russe il estime toutefois
qu'un compromis avec l'ukraine est à
portée de main une neutralité de
l'ukraine est selon lui évoqué sur le
modèle de la de la suède et de
l'autriche alors une idée depuis rejeté
avec avec force par la présidente la
présidence ukrainienne on va y revenir
mais avant cela les ingénieurs ce
bonjour le principe de neutralité à quoi
pense-t-il exactement alors qu'à quelque
chose de très précis en fait c'est la
neutralité c'est ce qu'ont choisi
plusieurs pays européens après la
deuxième guerre mondiale dans un
contexte de partage de l'europe entre
d'un côté les américains et les russes
soviétique de l'autre dans un contexte
de guerre froide naissante en gros pour
schématiser la neutralité c'est pas
d'adhésion à une alliance militaire vous
saviez cave et l'otan et le pacte de
varsovie d'un côté et pas de troupes
étrangères installées sur son sol alors
c'est une neutralité militaire mais ça
ne veut pas dire forcément neutralité
politique ni économique vous savez bien
que par exemple l'autriche fait partie
de l'union européenne
alors pour la suède la neutralité
suédoise s'est un peu en fait comme la
neutralité suisse a véritablement
fondements historiques très très très
anciens c'est encore un autre modèle en
fait la sienne n'a pas été en guerre
depuis 1815 elle est le traité de vienne
donc ça c'est vraiment un modèle à part
mais effectivement le modèle autrichien
lui pourrait peut-être inspiré inspiré
ce qui se passe en ukraine on a tendance
à oublier l'autriche tout comme
l'allemagne a été divisée en quatre
après la seconde guerre mondiale entre
les quatre forces d'occupation enfin les
quatre forces qui avait gagné la preuve
la deuxième guerre mondiale la france
les etats-unis la grande-bretagne et la
russie à l'époque l'allemagne on le sait
l'autriche on le sait moins ça a été
représentée par exemple dans le
troisième homme le film d'orson welles
pour vous donner un contexte en tout cas
ce qui se jouait à l'époque donc entre
1945 et 55 est énorme c'est à dire
c'était la souveraineté du pays
l'indépendance du pays et l'unité du
pays et autant l'allemagne et le
chancelier allemand avait fait a dit
n'avoir avait fait le choix de l'ancrage
à l'ouest ils baissent ndom autant les
autrichiens et le chancelier autrichien
avait fait le choix de la neutralité ce
qui lui a permis de sauver l'intégralité
de son pays de sa souveraineté et
l'autriche n'a pas été divisée en deux
comme ça a été le cas pour l'allemagne
un vrai concept donc vous venez de nous
rappeler l'histoire virginis sauf que le
cren visiblement n'y est absolument pas
prêtre la présidence ukrainienne rocher
quasiment dans la foulée la proposition
russe il n'y a pas de neutralité
envisagée oui absolument alors ce que
dit le négociateur russe et que le
modèle ne peut être que craignent un jeu
le site et surtout il veut des garanties
de sécurité absolue face à la russie
aujourd'hui dans le contexte de
neutralité par exemple on sait que oui
l'autriche est neutre mais par exemple
elle a adhéré à l'union européenne et
par là et là une garantie par exemple
qu'au ciel se fait attaquer l'autriche
elle aura la solidarité des autres pays
européens est passé ça que cherche le
crès c'est à dire à la limite peut-être
une neutralité sans fin c'est à dire ne
pas adhérer à l otan c'est d'ailleurs le
provost le président heinz qui a dit
avancer sur cette idée mais a besoin de
garanties de sécurité en face et vu le
manque de confiance qui a eu et l'unc
l'invasion enfin en tout cas l'attaquant
brusque qui jusqu'à présent la confiance
n'est pas établie donc voilà c'est
maintenant c'est aux européens et aux
russes certainement mais aux européens
et aux américains et aux membres de
l'otan de trouver peut-être une solution
pour pour ces garanties
merci beaucoup à dire